nie haben so viele Menschen in
Deutschland ein Dach über den Kopf
gebraucht der Wohnungsmarkt ist
irgendwie nie und trotzdem sind in
diesem Jahr die Nachfrage nach
Eigentumswohnungen zusammengebrochen
gegenüber den Vorjahresmonaten sind im
Februar und Januar Nachfragen für
Eigentumswohnungen um über 40%
zurückgegangen dass ergab eine neue
Studie von der Immobilienplattform
Immowelt Experten waren jetzt bereits
vor einem Platzen der Immobilienblase
insgesamt naja aber vielleicht kommt ja
jetzt auch die Zeit für Schnäppchenjäger
darüber sprechen wir jetzt hier in
dieser Sendung ja was sagen uns diese
Zahlen die interpretés du diesen
Rückgang welche Gründe siehst du dafür
wir haben ja schon wenn man auch ins
letzte Jahr schaut immer wieder zahlen
und auch Studien gehabt wonach es eine
Blase am Immobilienmarkt gab bzw mit
sinkenden Preisen gerechnet wird ich
persönlich ehrlicherweise glaube das
nicht so ganz denn die Faktoren sprechen
eigentlich dagegen wir haben einerseits
natürlich steigende Zinsen das ist
richtig aber wir haben auf dem auf der
anderen Seite einen auch leer gefegten
Wohnungsmarkt Leerstandsquoten die zum
Teil unter einem Prozent liegen wir
haben eher Zuzug nach Deutschland wenn
wir an die Ukraine denken wenn wir einen
Flüchtlinge aus anderen Ländern denken
also der der der Bedarf an Wohnraum der
wird in diesem Land eher größer als
kleiner und jetzt sehen wir ja auch dass
viele Bauprojekte gar nicht realisiert
werden aufgrund steigender Kosten und
auch das führt ja eher dazu dass das
Angebot nicht sehr viel größer wird aber
bei steigender Nachfrage und einem nicht
sehr viel größeren Angebot heißt das
automatisch die Preise müssen steigen
und dann hat man eben einmal den
Eindruck dass Häusle bauen das Häuser
kaufen das Häuser erwerben das wird zum
fast unerreichbaren Traum für viele das
ist leider so Fahrpreise steigen
deswegen wird das Angebot auch Knaller
ich rechne nicht mit sinkenden
Immobilienpreisen hat es ein bisschen in
der Geschichte von Deutschland nie
gegeben es hatte eine Geschichte als
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg immer nur
sogenannte rechtstendenzen gegenüber
spricht die Preise sind gleich geblieben
und nicht gestiegen und dann sind sie
wieder gestiegen aber signifikante
Rückgänge im privaten Wohnungsmarkt hat
es nicht gegeben die Eigentumsquote ist
dennoch in Deutschland nicht besonders
hoch nur in der Schweiz herr Meier da
ist sie dann noch niedriger muss man
sagen wir erklären Sie sich das kann man
sich einfach nicht leisten wir sind ein
Volk von Mietern so viel ich weiß und
wir sind dann Volk von Suchenden Mietern
in den letzten 20 Jahren haben sich die
Mieten verdoppelt und das ist ein großes
Thema bei uns denn es gibt
wohnungsnotstand aber eben es ist auch
sehr schwierig was zu finden dass man
überhaupt noch bezahlen kann vor allem
als Familie also in Zürich
Dreizimmerwohnung 3000 Franken da und da
gibt's nichts wer kann sich das denn
noch leisten was bedeutet das alle
ziehen immer weiter raus
es ist vieles wird abgerissen und
diejenigen die da gewohnt haben müssen
woanders hin und Leute kommen rein die
deutlich mehr verdienen wir sehen es
auch in Deutschland ganz klar die
Inflation die Lebensmittelpreise um 27
Prozent dann noch mal rauf man fragt
sich wie viel kann man sich noch leisten
man fragt sich aber auch droht da so
eine richtige armutswelle die jetzt ins
Rollen kommt also ich glaube man muss
ein bisschen unterscheiden auch gerade
bei den Immobilienpreisen du hast es
natürlich in der Großstadt in begehrten
Standorten da wird das weiter hochgehen
da glaube ich auch nicht dass die runter
gehen auf dem Lande sieht das z.B ganz
anders aus da gibt es Gegenden wo die
Preise massiv gefallen sind und wo es
wirklich auch schwierig ist überhaupt
ein Haus zu verkaufen also hast eine
totale statt landschere und insbesondere
auch in den attraktiven Standorten in
Rhein-Main Gebiet Düsseldorf Köln
München ist ja absurd was da teilweise
abläuft du hast ja auf der einen Seite
jetzt diese US-Konzerne die da hingehen
mit Google und Apple die da
riesenstandorte aufbauen ist natürlich
eine tolle Nachricht für den Standort
München auf der anderen Seite
explodieren jetzt dort die Mietpreise
und gleichzeitig die Menschen auch
zutiefst verunsichert sie denken sich
wie muss ich dämmen was ist mit der
Wärmepumpe kommt daher auch diese Kauf
Zurückhaltung dass man überhaupt gar
nicht mehr dahin kommt zu sagen man
erfüllt sich mit aller Kraft diesen
Traum vom Häusle bauen nein ich glaube
das einfach von 0% Zinsen auf 4% Zinsen
mit eher steigender Tendenz und einer
Zurückhaltung der Banken zu finanzieren
viele Leute sich einfach die geforderten
Kaufpreise nicht leisten können oder
auch nicht leisten wollen muss sagen
warum ist die Eigentumswohnung in der
Schweiz und in Deutschland so niedrig
das liegt natürlich an der Sicherheit
des Mieters also ich fliege hier nicht
raus wenn ich die Miete bezahle das ist
in Amerika anders das ist in Spanien
anders das sind die Italien anders das
heißt wenn ich da sicher irgendwo wohnen
bleiben will dann muss ich kaufen und
deswegen sind Leute viel stärker
gezwungen in den Kauf zu gehen deswegen
sind ist kann man da auch das nicht so
genau vergleichen deswegen ist die
Schweiz noch stärker aber Deutschland
eigentlich auch gerade in den Städten im
Media Markt und wird auch bleiben sie
auch die Verunsicherung und schreiben
auch viele Menschen hier die Sendung
verfolgen ich muss jetzt ich habe mein
Leben lang für ein Haus gearbeitet jetzt
haben wir unsere Häuschen wir wollen
unser Lebensabend genießen aber jetzt
kommt ich muss dämmen ich brauche die
Wärmepumpe ich muss auf die Energie
schauen die Preise sind aber
gleichzeitig teurer geworden und
plötzlich muss ich 160.000 € in etwa
aufbringen ja da müssen sie ja schon
ziemlichen Palast haben wenn sie 160 000
€
da braucht man großes Grundstück hat mir
jemanden hier in der Sendung der hat ein
großes Grundstücken kleines Häuschen
Grundsteuer ist ja eine Erhöhung die
durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht
gekommen ist weil wir eine weil wir die
Wohnungen oder die Häuser niedriger
bewertet haben als andere ist jetzt und
das hat das Verfassungsgericht für
Verfassungsgericht ist eine anderes
Thema aber jetzt beim Thema Heizung
wobei ganz kurz auch da die Erhöhung
kommt durch die Kommunen zustande es
geht nur um die Berechnungsgrundlage die
Kommunen hätten die Möglichkeit die
hebelsätze natürlich zu senken und
machen
da bin ich gespannt welche Kommunen das
macht das glaube ich bis heute nicht
bevor sie nicht da ist also es heißt
nicht dass es teurer werden muss es ist
immer nennt in der Politik natürlich zu
sagen wir versuchen das irgendwie teurer
zu machen weil es einfach ist die Bürger
abzukassieren aber das
Verfassungsgericht hat nicht gesagt das
ist toller werden muss ich glaube schon
dass diese Verunsicherung bei den
Hausbesitzern gerade bei den älteren
momentan extrem ist also es ist diese
Grundsteuer Geschichte gab da rief meine
über 80-jährige Mutter an und war mit
diesen ganzen Ablauf völlig überfordert
und jetzt fragt sie sich was muss ich
jetzt mit meiner Heizung machen also die
Kommunikation die dort auch momentan von
der Regierung stattfindet die ich glaube
die überfordert viele Menschen total und
da gibt's ja auch Stimmen die sagen
einfach leisten kann eine kleinere
Wohnung vielleicht weiter nach draußen
ist macht was mit Menschen glauben Sie
nicht
ja aber bei das ist ja dann bei den
bestandsmietern so dass man rauszieht es
ist eine Schwierigkeit gerade auf dem
Land wo ich keine Fernwärme bekomme etc
ich meine Heizung umbaue die richtige
Lösung sind lokale nahwärmesysteme das
muss aber die Kommunalpolitik umsetzen
und das kennen dazu wenige aber das wäre
eigentlich die richtige Lösung mit
erneuerbaren Energien und kommunalen
werbeplänen dass ich als Eigentümer weiß
okay in sieben Jahren kommt eine
Wärmeleitung vorbei und dann kann ich so
lange natürlich meine alte Heizung
behalten
dass wir die richtige Lösung soweit sind
wir aber in Deutschland in vielen
Stellen es geht natürlich auch im
Eigentümer nicht nur Mieter sondern es
geht um Eigentümer die nicht mehr wissen
wie Sie diese Kosten tragen sollen und
die natürlich auch mit der Angst leben
müssen dass sie ihr Haus und für ganz
viele ist das so ich bau mir das ein
Leben lang auf und damit bin ich sicher
zumindest gedanklich mit diesem Spiel im
Kopf sich auseinander finden
auseinandersetzen müssen Sie dieses Haus
verlassen müssen verkaufen müssen
also ich denke das nicht also das ist
leider einige fürchten ja aber man kann
sie glaube ich beruhigen ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass wir keine Lösung
bekommen bei der wir nicht
sozialverträglich das für alle irgendwie
leistbar machen der Bundesregierung
auch die Politik in dieser Sendung
deswegen bin ich kurz davor zu sagen
dann dürfen wir die Zuschriften darf ich
Ihnen die direkt weiterleiten
Oppositionspartei bin mit den
Beschlüssen nicht zufrieden die die
Lampe Regierung gemacht hat also dürfen
Sie gerne weiterleiten wo ich kann das
Problem leider nicht lösen aber nochmal
die auch Olaf Scholz heute im Deutschen
Bundestag hat versprochen keiner wird
alleine gelassen das heißt jeder
Eigentümer jetzt wollen wir mal gucken
dass die das Versprechen noch einlösen
wir wenigstens drauf achten gut sie
haben ein Auge drauf herr Meier wir
reden ja hier gleich noch in der Sendung
über so ein paar Träume die vielleicht
platzen können was glauben Sie was macht
das mit Menschen wenn man sich so ein
Lebenstraum aufbaut und die Gefahr die
Sorgen werden unterschiedlich jetzt hier
in den Tisch eingeschätzt wenn man sich
so ein Haus Traum erfüllt mir viel viel
Arbeit und dann sitzt man für den Kosten
raten Sie dazu so einer ich sag mal
Rationalität wird schon alles gut werden
schaffen wir schon oder wie sehen Sie
das sie haben auch eine Kolumne die
heißt ich will jetzt ihren Ratschlag
auch ja habe ich tatsächlich
glücklicherweise ist es sind die Fragen
die da reinkommen nicht von solcher
Komplexität ich kann hier nur mutmaßen
grundsätzlich ist wohnen ein Grundrecht
das ist ja was wirklich
fundamentales wortwörtlich und wenn da
dran gerüttelt wird aus welcher Richtung
auch immer dann dann erzeugt das
Unwohlsein und Angst also ich spreche
immer wieder mit Leuten und die hätten
eigentlich das Geld aber diese Mieter
Angst die wir die wir hier spüren gerade
in der Schweiz die ist doch beträchtlich
kann ich die Wohnung behalten wenn ich
Streit habe mit einem Nachbarn bringt
überhaupt was zu suchen kann ich mir das
dann leisten und das das geht schon ans
Eingemachte das ist nicht das Auto oder
der Job das ist das Leben würden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
für Sie